[Musique]
g Babinet bonjour bonjour Je vous
interview aujourd'hui pour un site
internet qui s'appelle ser viw et ben
bienvenue j'aurais voulu avoir votre
avis sur les questions de Big Data
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
c'est un vaste sujet mais bon je pense
c'est avant tout une technologie c'estd
que c'est pas une religion et à ce titre
ça offre des opportunités
fantastiques mais et aussi des menaces
et des enjeux de vie privée relativement
importants je donne un exemple que moi
micher et je pense qu'il résume assez
bien le propos c'est avec les Big Data
je peux assez
facilement réussir à
prédire l'état de
santé des gens à partir du moment où
j'ai donné j'ai des données en grand
nombre des données d'historicité de
santé par exemple de l'ADN ou des choses
comme ça la question c'est de savoir
comment est-ce qu'on organise ça est-ce
que on organise ça de façon individuelle
est-ce que onorganise de façon
collective est-ce que on l'organise de
façon systématique est-ce qu'on le fait
en mode optin euh et c'est quoi le mode
op-tin le mode op-tin c'est sur le le
consentement volontaire c'estàdire que
je dis je suis d'accord pour que mes mes
données de santé soient traitées et à
partir de là on pourrait dire voilà on
prévient les gens on leur donne des
conseils sur la façon dont il devrait
faire euh euh se soigner euh s'alimenter
et cetera et cetera donc ça c'est un
rapport évidemment extrêmement différent
entre les institutions et les individus
parce que ça veut dire queon accepte de
confier des données extrêmement
sensibles euh aux institutions pour
qu'elles puisse nous dire attention si
vous faites pas ça dans 6 mois dans 1 an
dans 2 ans vous allez avoir une maladie
grave coronarienne de chronique de de
tout type donc de même on pourrait très
facilement dire dans la dans une
population donnée c'est pas la peine de
vacciner tout le monde de la gripe
chaque hiver on peut repérer les gens
qui sont les plus sensible et les
inviter à aller se se faire vacciner et
à contrario on peut aussi dire à
d'autres gens vous c'est pas la peine de
vous vacciner parce que vous avez une
sensibilité qui est faible à l'égard de
du virus qui arrive donc ça c'est
typiquement l'enjeu des Big Data mais on
voit bien que le postulat initial c'est
la confiance s'il y a pas de confiance
dans le système de santé euh il y a des
possibilités de déviance d'une part et
auelà de ça dans le système de santé ou
dans les institutions ben là je parle à
l'égard de la santé hein mais c'est vrai
pour tout c'est-à-dire que euh par
exemple si je prends euh les transports
en commun ou les transports en général
euh on peut du coup l'optimisation des
transports en commun grâce à la Big Data
voilà on peut optimiser mais non
seulement les transports en commun mais
aussi mes déplacements personnels
c'està-dire que euh par exemple je pour
avoir une sorte de système qui va
chercher dans mon agenda et qui va
repérer que je vais au travail à telle
heure et donc qui va optimiser le les
horreurs des bus en fonction des
intérêts collectifs c'est-à-dire qui va
dire voilà il y a dans ce quartier il y
a 30 personnes qui vont au travail à T
heure donc on modifie en temps réel
entre guillemets les horaires de bus
parce qu'on voit que c'est plus
pertinent et en l'occurrence ça ferait
disparaître les horaires si si si vous
deviez vous faire la ok du diable et
alors bon voilà donc tout ça repose sur
le principe de confiance euh dans les
systèmes et le principe de juste
réciprocité euh mais c'est évident que
euh euh on peut avoir des glissements
très importants c'est-à-dire qu'il y ait
plus de réciprocité et que ça sert à
abuser de nous donc l'exemple garde de
la santé c'est évidemment les assureurs
donc les assurances complémentaires et
on se dit euh ils vont refuser d'assurer
des gens ou ils vont les assurer très
cher
et cetera et cetera euh et ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas de réciprocité puisqu'il y
a un abus euh des données qui sont
utilisé au-delà de ce qu'on veut et il y
a plus le sens de la solidarité c'est le
sens commun de la
répartition du système de santé enfin de
l'utilisation du système de santé euh et
donc je crois que euh les postulats qui
président à la mise en place de Big Data
de façon efficace c'est une grande
transparence démocratique et un débat
euh sur le modèle que l'on souhaite
parce que je pense que comme ces
systèmes n'ont pas été pensés euh ça
nécessite de se poser la question de
savoir comment on veut les utiliser vous
vous vous parlez de débat euh est-ce que
vous avez suivi comment la loi de
programmation militaire a été passée
est-ce que vous trouvez qu'en ce moment
il y a du débat autour de ces questions
ou c'est question posé ouais ouais j'ai
trouvé que c'était assez intéressant
donc moi je me suis insurgé contre la
l'article 13 versus 20 euh de la loi de
programmation militaire et en fait je
l'ai fait je l'ai fait parce que j'ai
compris finalement assez
tardivement
que les les institutions ne comprennent
pas ou en tout cas ne veulent pas
comprendre les risques que les modèles
institutionnels qu'elle créent génèent
je
m'explique jusqu'à présent on
considérait que les écoutes ce genre de
choses c'était relativement restreints
des choses qui étaient relativement
restreintes et qui étaient cantonné à un
aspect technico-technique et donc on
pouvait créer une sorte d'entité qui
allait être chargée de faire ça et on a
continué dans cette direction et le
problème que j'ai avec les systèmes
d'écoute c'est que ils sont rattachés à
l'exécutif et ils transmettent au
pouvoir judiciaire les résultats de
l'enquête mais de ce fait on
biaèise la base même des principes
démocratiques
euh qui sont la séparation des pouvoirs
euh et de fait euh l'esprit des lois et
enfin de montescu en l'occurrence est
particulièrement maltraité c'estàd que
je vois pas dans un modèle actuel ce qui
empêche pour ceux qui se souviennent de
ça une arfaire Rainbow Warrior où
l'exécutif avait complètement comment
dire truqué les éléments d'enquête de se
reproduire et de fait la la notion de de
fonctionnement normal de la démocratie
être préservé parce que je rappelle que
les écoutes sont faites par une
institution militaire euh sur requête ou
non d'ailleurs du juge et par ailleurs
la police judiciaire donc qui est
chargée d'instruire les enquêtes est
rattaché évidemment au ministère de
l'Intérieur et donc n'est pas
indépendante non plus donc il y a un
vrai risque euh de perversion entre
guillemets du système je pense que
maintenant que nos vies sont massivement
numériques c'est-à-dire que si je porte
des objets
connectés ma vie réelle elle est elle
est très facilement monitorable
monitorable je pense que le il faut se
reposer la question de l'organisation de
nos institutions et y compris de
l'indépendance de la police judiciaire
parce que voilà moi je je considère que
les les outils d'enquête numérique sont
plus faciles à à pervertir à truqué
parce que c'est c'est virtuel et donc on
peut introduire des dossiers dans les
ordinateurs des gens que que la vraie
vie que dans la vraie vie parce que dans
la vraie vie vous avez des témoins vous
avez des des tierces parties vous avez
des preuves matérielles qui restent ou
pas et c'est relativement différent je
pense
que le législateur soit par
ignorance soit par mauvais esprit entre
guillemets a fait vraiment une erreur
préjudici
au fonctionnement de la justice et d'une
façon plus générale de la démocratie en
mettant en place cet article 13 200 euh
et je crois qu'il est encore temps de
revenir là-dessus comment comment on
fait à l'échelle du citoyen pour
repenser ses institutions ou pour
reprendre le contrôle de ces
institutions mais le c'est un vrai sujet
c'est même le sujet je pense c'est que
euh le on se rend pas compte qu'on est
en train de changer d'air et moi je
crois qu'on passe de l'aire de la 2e
révolution industrielle à une are de la
3e révolution industrielle qui est celle
de la data et que ça pose des problèmes
éthiques fondamentaux et qui nécessite
un débat citoyen euh et ce débat n'a pas
lieu il a pas lieu parce que nos
institutions considèrent que c'est le
cours normal des choses l'évolution
normale des choses et d'ailleurs la
régulation qui nous est imposée qui est
mise en place par nos institutions c'est
une régulation qui est décalée parce que
elle continuer elle continue à à à
réguler proforma comme si on était
toujours dans une ère dans laquelle on n
plus et donc moi je crois que euh un
c'est essentiel que le monde politique
soit éduqué à ces enjeux-là et puis
au-delà de ça je pense que il y a un
réveil citoyen qui est indispensable et
euh je crois que on peut avoir un débat
serein sur ces enjeux je crois que c'est
pas maniqué c'est-à-dire que les
technologies permettent de faire des
choses intéressantes permettent aussi de
faire des choses négatives et que il
faut éviter que il y ait une opposition
entre les pros et les contre mais que on
fasse la part des choses et qu'on crée
un environnement institutionnel qui nous
permette de réussir cette transition
dans cette nouvelle are lorsque vous
étiez au Conseil National du Numérique
est-ce que vous aviez l'impression
d'être écouté
euh curieusement non j'ai pas eu le
sentiment d'être écouté
euh je assez curieusement j'ai j'ai eu
le sentiment d'avoir une relative
indépendance il y a eu des choses sur
lesquelles ça s'est pas hyper bien passé
je crois que notamment on a eu la
volonté d'avoir une voix assez libre
qu'est-ce qui s'est mal passé ce qui
s'est mal passé à plusieurs reprises on
a exprimé un avis très librement sans
sans entre guillemets passer par le le
canal officiel et ça ça nous a été
reproché ce que je peux comprendre et de
fait comme je le racontais dans dans mon
livre nous on considérait que il fallait
entre guillemets être une sorte de
guerria positive c'està-dire de d'être
dans le dialogue mais en même temps
d'afficher très radicalement ce qui nous
semblait être une nouvelle voix euh
radicalement ou franchement franchement
franchement c'està dire de dire de pas
de pas mettre d'eau dans notre vin et de
dire voilà ceci système fonctionne pas
du tout et d'ailleurs de mémoire je
crois que le premier avis qu'on a v
c'était sur une directive Paquet Télécom
et sur des enjeu de liberté publique je
suis pas sûr mais je crois que je suis à
peu près et ça c'était le surlendemain
de la création du CNN ou dans la
première semaine de la création du CNN
et je su CIS que ça a un peu donné le
ton c'était assez drôle je vais ouvrir
une parenthèse parce que vous parlez de
télécom qu'est-ce que vous pensez de des
relations un petit peu incestueuses
entre Orange et la DGSE alors j'ai
entendu parler de ça objectivement je je
voudrais pas dire de bêtis j'ai pas
investigué outre mesure ça euh si c'est
vrai c'est évidemment extrêmement
problématique euh et
euh je je connais pas bien le dossier
donc j'aurais pas dire de bêtises voilà
on ferme la parenthèse euh que
manque-t-il au Conseil national du
numérique pour peser dans la
balance le le Conseil actuel bon il est
un peu nouveau donc je je sais pas si je
pourrais mettre un avis euh
euh moi moi je pense qu'il faut avoir
une certaine radicalité c'est-à-dire que
euh on est face à des gens qui parce
qu'ils viennent d'une autre are ne
comprennent pas bien les enjeux en
question et on l'impression que c'est
subsidiaire euh et donc je pense qu'il
faut il faut émettre avec un un certain
à propos radical euh des des avis il
faut s'assurer
que ça prise sur la société civile
c'està-dire que moi je rêve de
concertation très large sur les enjeux
de Data par exemple euh je pense que les
enjeux de Data sont extrêmement
extrêmement ambitieux en terme de
potentiel euh et que ça nécessite non
pas
euh une réponse immédiate mais euh une
discussion permanente euh sur tout un
tas de de sujet de société euh par
exemple est-ce que on crée des identités
électroniques et si oui dans quelle
mesure on garantit que ça va pas être
une source d'abus euh quel est le le
type de système de Big Data qu'on peut
envisager à sur différents thèmes
différents terrains euh est-ce que
l'éducation numérique doit
être quelque chose de systématique et
quel type d'éducation numérique et
cetera et cetera tout ça c'est des
enjeux qui sont importants et moi je
n'ai pas envie de les confier
exclusivement à des gens que je
considèreent être finalement les plus
soumis à la fracture numérique parce que
pour régulièrement parler avec des
hommes politiques mais aussi
avec différentes classes de la société
c'est là où je vois la plus grande
fracture numérique c'est que les gens
qui se font imprimer leur mail euh c'est
pas
des gens qui sont ouvriers en province
c'est un petit peu comme les les juges
qui ont jugé l'affaire Bluetooth ah
ouais incroyable avec Google allez un
petit peu un petit mot là-dessus là on
ça c'est mais c'est pour moi ça m'étonne
pas c'est juste le cours normal des
institution donc des juges
qui n'ont pas été juste éduqués à ces
notions là pourquoi parce que il y a un
la classe d'âge en général les gens qui
sont à la tête de ce pays bah ils sont
plus vieux que la moyenne des Français
d'ailleurs les jeunes vont pas voter
parce qu'ils se sentent pas représentés
et puis au-delà de ça il y a l'isolement
institutionnel c'estàd que quand on
appartient à une institution d'État on
est un peu hors sol et de fait on voit
pas la vraie vie on VO on la voit moins
qu'ailleurs et donc effectivement on
assiste à des conséquences et je trouve
que c'est plutôt intéressant cette
affaire Bluetooth c'està- dire que là ça
montre vraiment de façon extrêmement
concrète ce qui se passe et que moi
lorsque je je le dis on me dit mais là
tu exagères c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe et cetera bah si ça se passe
partout comme ça dans l'état ils ne
comprennent pas ces gens jeux du tout
alors vous vous avez déclaré dans une
interview que lail était un ennemi de la
nation
oui et j'ai je pense que j'ai pas été
forcément bien compris par tout le
monde lorsque j'ai dit ça mon propos
c'était de dire que c'est exactement ce
que je viens de dire c'est que je vois
pas pourquoi laacnil isquerait le débat
à l'égard de la donnée en disant voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on va la réguler pour
moi le problème de la clinil c'est que
ils nont cessé de dire ouais tout ça
c'est très dangereux et moi je crois
qu'à la fin le message que je percevais
c'est le mieux pour que ça arrive pas
c'est qu'il y en ait pas et je pense que
euh qui en a pas ou qui est mieux plus
divers diversifié oui mais c'est pas ce
que dit l'acnil c'est en tout cas il y a
plusieurs kniles il y a laacnil je pense
avant cette déclaration et depuis a une
évolution dans le débat dans la la prise
de position de l'acnil là-dessus mais
encore une fois euh le problème de
l'acnil c'est le cantonnement au sein
d'une institution administrative d'un
débat qui est un débat qui nous concerne
tous euh et je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
laisser l'acnil ou par ailleurs la Haute
Autorité de Santé
décider la façon dont nos données doit
doit être traité moi j'aurais tendance à
dire que personnellement je préfère que
mes données soient plus larg
utilisé mais que j'ai une plus grande
transparence sur la compréhension des
enjeux la façon dont elles sont
utilisées et une plus grande capacité à
pouvoir décider ou non par exemple c'est
un sacré objectif je vous coupe c'est un
sacré objectif à l'heure actuelle on est
dans l'aair pratiquement de la perte de
confiance généralisée sans tomber dans
les théories conspirationnistes ou
contestataire ou réactionnaire les
journalistes ne sont plus écoutés les
hommes politiques ont perdu euh la
confiance de leurs électeurs euh le vote
contestataire se manifeste à travers le
le le vote du Front national sans même
je dirais que des des gens votent Front
national sans même adhérer à leurs idées
uniquement pour avoir un vote
contestataire là on touche sur un un
débat qui est très très sensible à votre
avis quel est le l'organisme ou la la
l'évolution des consciences qui pourrait
apporter ce le rétablissement de cette
confiance dans dans la gestion de nos
données le Big Data c'est quelque chose
qui peut être très salutaire pour
l'évolution d'une société mais qui peut
être aussi très très néfaste qu'est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce qu'on fait un débat
est-ce qu'on fait un forum est-ce que
vous voulez être le faire de lance pour
fédérer cette cette nouvelle air de la
confiance autour du Big datata est-ce
que vous êtes prêt à tendre la main à
des hackurs à tendre la main à des gens
un petit peu moins représentatifs mais
beaucoup plus proche de la population
alors c'est le cœur du du réacteur ce
dont on parle pour répondre à la
première partie de la question c'est moi
je crois que une des raisons qui font
que ce pays a pas confiance dans ces
institutions c'est la nature même de ces
institutions qui sont néomonarchiques
c'estd extrêmement verticalisé on est le
pays au monde où il y a le plus d'élus
il y a 600000 élus en France 630000 élus
c'est unique au monde rapportter par
habitant ça fait un élu pour 100
habitants et de fait on fait ça moi ma
conviction c'est pour priver
l'expression de la
société civile directe la démocratie
directe voilà c'est l'enfermement du
débat au sein de spécialiste et on est
un une société qui est fascinée par
l'élitisme par l'élite par les élites et
je constate que dans beaucoup de pays on
fait évoluer le cadre institutionnel
pour inclure la société civile dans le
débat et on est très loin de faire ça en
France je pense c'est même un peu la
terreur des institutions c'estàd que moi
je crois que c'est par peur des Jaris
euh donc de province que on a créé des
institutions qui ont cette forme là et
il me semble que à une époque où
les institutions perd du pied par
rapport à cette nouvelle donne
technologique on doit soit leur imposer
de changer de forme soit créer le débat
à côté des institutions effectivement
imposer comment ben je pense en leur
montrant que ils ne comprennent pas donc
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai souvent des
mots assez dur à l'égard de du pouvoir
politique parce que je considère qu'ils
mettent le pays dans le mur et que
au-delà de ça il favorise l'émergence de
pensée radicale notamment du Front
national de ce genre de choses parce que
ça fait 30 ou 40 ans que il nous
impose une alternance de débat entre la
droite et la gauche qui ne sont pas la
solution c'est en gros c'est le débat
c'est est-ce qu'on fait une société de
l'offre une société de la demande et je
pense que à l'air du numérique c'est
plus l'enjeu c'est plus l'enjeu par
exemple les enjeux de la gratuité du
travail gratuit de d'avoir des
plateformes open c'est absolument pas au
cœur du débat politique et ça devient
tellement significatif je rappelle que
le Bureau of statistique américain a dit
maintenant dans la croissance américaine
il y a les chiffres qu'on peut mesurer
de façon monétaire mais il y a aussi une
part de travail gratuit quand on accède
à Wikipédia on accède à la richesse mais
on paye pas pour ça et donc ça c'est
cette notion là elle peut paraître
l'intelligence collaborative ouais
l'intelligence collaborative exactement
c'est ces notionsl ces notionsl moi je
pense qu'elle devrait faire partie du
débat politique ell elles en font
absolument pas partie mais pas seulement
la démocratie directe c'est aussi un
enjeu euh de débat politique et je pense
que ils vont continuer à avoir un
effritement de leur confiance tant que
ils prendront pas en compte la dimension
de la société numérique qui a des des
fondements qui n'ont rien à voir avec
ceux que l'on connaît actuellement donc
pour répondre à la question euh je pense
que oui le problème c'est qu'il y a pas
ce débat qu'il faut ce débat oui moi je
m'implique pour le faire émerger et
j'essaie de trouver des
plateformes
avec
différentes institutions différentes
associations pour réfléchir à ça j'étais
en train encore ce matin et hier
d'envoyer des mails à ce propos euh je
sais pas exactement comment ça peut se
faire et oui évidemment toutes les
bonnes volonté sont bienvenu pour par de
volonté euh je voudrais votre avis sur
les
hackurs qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors je connais pas bien le monde des
hackeurs j'en rencontre évidemment mais
il y a pas de labellisation officielle
des des
hackeurs moi je je je il y a plusieurs
choses dans on va dire ce que m'évoque
la notion de hackur pour moi il y a la
notion de la pensée alternative qui est
intéressante parce que c'est euh rompre
la pensée commune et dire bah on peut
faire les choses de façon différente ça
c'est évidemment quelque chose que je
suis euh que je je respecte beaucoup il
y a le principe du contrepouvoir et euh
évidemment dans une période actuelle où
euh finalement on a des choses qui sont
chuchotées qui sont pas exprimées avoir
ce contrepouvoir c'est bien et je suis
évidemment très favorable à ça je pense
que les cœur doivent aussi émettre des
idées donc pas uniquement être
dans les notions de code et de choses
qui sont pas forcément comprises par le
grand public mais doivent participer au
débat public puis il y a la il y a la
troisième notion c'est la cœur un peu
noir évidemment moi je peux pas adhérer
à des gens qui ont des comportements
c'est une minorité c'est une minorité
qui sont évidemment une minorité je le
pense aussi en général euh une petite
trois petites questions
vous avez reçu le titre de Digital
champion est-ce que vous trouvez que
c'est un petit peu ridicule pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas digital superhéros digital
superstar j'adoreraai digital superhéros
ça m'irait très bien je veux bien mettre
une cap si une si Bruxelles change le
titre d'accord deux dernières questions
Gill Babinet
donne si possible jeunes générations qui
nous écoutent sur internet donnezleur
des conseils des préconisations qui que
si vous aviez à laisser une bouteille à
la mer sur Internet l'immortalité de ce
conseil qu'est-ce que vous laisseriez à
ces jeunes générations alors il y a il y
a plusieurs types de conseils il y a les
conseils de façon à l'égard de la vie
professionnelle de de ce genre de choses
donc moi je bon c'est idiot de le dire
mais je pense
que le fait de maîtriser un peu le code
c'est c'est bien mais ça mérite d'être
dit même si je suis pas forcément devant
les gens qui
sont le plus à même de de faire
attention à ce qu'on sait puisquils sont
déjà
là-dedans je je je pense que la pensée
alternative c'est important c'estàd que
on est dans un monde qui privilégie la
pensée unique plus que jamais et dès
qu'on commence à sortir du cadre on n
plus dans le cadre donc je pense j'ai
aucun respect pour ce que je dis assez
souvent c'est que dans les années 60 on
a eu une florison de philosophe et de
pens alternative et c'était une époque
où on pouvait pas faire l'utopie et
aujourd'hui on est dans une
révolution conceptuelle technologique
qui est mené par le monde du numérique
et que on voit pas de pensée alternatif
pas beaucoup et donc je crois que c'est
important de l'exprimer et la troisème
chose que je dirais à la jeunesse c'est
n'attendez pas qu'on vous donne le
pouvoir prenez-le qu'il faut bien
comprendre
que partout
les gens qui détiennent le pouvoir ne
vous le donneront pas ils vont le garder
et le garderont de façon illégitime et
ça moi je le vois partout tout le temps
et ce qui est très bizarre d'ailleurs
c'est que par exemple l'autre jour
j'étais dans un journal et on
disait voilà vous faites partie de la
jeune génération j'ai 47 ans je
considère que c'est ça montre bien
combien il y a un décalage c'estd que en
gros les gens qui sont pouvoir en 60 ans
la génération montante à plus de 40 ans
et le reste c'est des mineurs perpétu
donc on peut pas laisser les choses
continuer comme ça j Babinet merci merci
[Musique]
beaucoup l'idée de la commission
trilatéral vient de David Rockfeller il
y a 35 ans il a
réuni quelques dizaines d'Européens
d'Américains de japonais en leur disant
écoutez on a des problèmes en commun euh
par
exemple les relations avec la Chine par
exemple les relations avec ce qui était
à l'époque
l'URSS essayons d'avoir des positions
communes qui soient dans l'intérêt
général on est dans la captation de
données le recueil de données dit la loi
c'est-à-dire qu'on va chercher chez des
prestataires chez des intermédiires
technique on va chercher des données
toutes données ça peut être des
courriels électroniques des courriels
des courriel électroniques ça peut re
des données bancaires ça peut être des
mot de passe c'est tout ça dont il
s'agit demain c'est permanent et j'éta
surpris de voir que né pas sensibilis à
ça est on peut très bien basculer vers
un régime beaucoup moinsocti avec des
valeursécemment encore une FO pasign ça
fa tout ceon en
placeutilisé légitim par gver oc V au
pouvoir et pourrait automatiser un
génnocide ou automatiser des
arrestations en masse et c'est ça qui me
fait peur tant qu'on est dans un état
démocratique je CIS je ve faire bien je
veux bien faire confiance à nos états
[Musique]